Grossberg it's great to learn because
knowledge is power functions are the
backbone of JavaScript development yet
also one of the most difficult concepts
to master but once you understand
functions everything else in the
language becomes relatively easy we'll
start from the absolute basics then go
into practical examples of arrow
functions closures higher-order
functions recursion and we'll even talk
about some common best practices for
writing high-quality JavaScript code
welcome to episode 4 of the full course
JavaScript function if you're new here
like and subscribe and you can follow
the full free course on fire ship IO now
in order to understand a function let's
start by dissecting it and looking at
its anatomy what we're looking at here
is a function declaration also called a
function definition or statement it
starts with the function keyword then
you need to choose a name for it and you
should choose something that's readable
to other human beings because there's a
good saying there's only two hard things
in computer science cache and validation
naming things and off-by-one errors in
other words choosing the right name for
your function is almost as hard as
making a joke about programming but once
you decide on a name the next step is to
add parentheses and then add any
parameters or inputs to the function you
can think of a parameter as a variable
that this function lot access to when
it's called and then from there we have
curly braces and everything inside is
the function body and that's where you
define all your logic the function body
will typically do one of two things
it will either perform a task or return
a value or possibly both an example of a
function performing a task is a console
log and because there's no return
statement it will implicitly return
undefined but a function body might also
contain a return statement and that
allows us to take the value that was
calculated inside the function body and
set it as a variable now at this point
we've declared a function which
describes what the code will do but in
order to actually execute it we need to
call the function we do that by
referencing the function by its name and
then we pass in actual values as
arguments to the parameters so imagine
you get asked on an interview what is
the difference between a parameter and
an argument you might say something like
parameters are the variable inputs that
you use in the function definition while
arguments are the actual values or
expressions used when calling the
function so what we just looked at there
was a named function declaration but
there's also a thing called a function
rushon which basically means using a
function as a value let's go ahead and
refactor our declaration to an
expression we'll use the same function
name but instead set it as a variable
and then use an anonymous function which
is just a function without a name as the
value now when calling these functions
they will produce an identical result
and if you watch the previous video you
might know that the function declaration
is hoisted while the expression is not
the function declaration will always be
put at the top of the scope which means
you can make calls to the function even
if it's declared somewhere later in the
code but when you have an expression the
function doesn't actually get created
until that code is reached in the script
and that means you get an error if you
try to call it beforehand so now that
you know the difference between a
function declaration and expression
which one should you use well there's
actually no universal best practice here
but I think most people today would lean
towards function expressions because
they're not hoisted it makes it easier
to understand where they belong in the
context of an application and they're
less likely to pollute the global
namespace and speaking of that a cool
thing you can do is create an
immediately invoked function expression
by wrapping an anonymous function in
parentheses you can then call it
immediately by adding parentheses
afterwards but I think that looks goofy
because what we're talking about is the
whole invocation but we got these things
hanging outside of it looking sort of
like dog balls you know
what's important is the whole invocation
so I would put the parents around it
that's better I think so now let's go
ahead and switch gears and take a closer
look at parameters and arguments as you
can see here we have three parameters a
main aside and a drink and if we want to
log those out at runtime we can do
console log arguments which is a keyword
built into JavaScript this particular
function takes three positional
arguments and that means when you call
this function you need to pass in your
arguments in the right order
that's pretty manageable when you have
three arguments but imagine we had five
or ten arguments to a function things to
get out of hand very quickly but when
you run into a situation like that a
common solution is to use an object for
named parameters the make lunch function
only has one single argument but that
argument is an object that can contain
multiple values and that means we can D
structure the object or use it directly
inside the function body so with this
approach you don't have to worry about
the order of the arguments and also
makes it more flexible to extend your
code with non breaking changes in the
future
now one other trick that JavaScript has
up its sleeve is rest parameters in the
make dinner function we have a single
parameter but it's preceded by three
dots that allows us to call the function
with multiple positioned arguments and
then access them as an array inside the
function body now at this point we've
only been looking at the function
keyword but there's actually a more
compact and concise way to write your
functions and that's using the arrow
syntax let's go ahead and refactor one
of our earlier function expressions to
use the arrow syntax we start with a
variable to provide a name then we have
parentheses with the parameters to the
function and then we have an arrow that
points to the function body a cool thing
about the syntax is that if you omit
curly braces then it will implicitly
return that value from the function and
that means that three lines of code now
become one now if you have additional
work to do inside the function you can
still add brackets in which case you
would still need to add a return
statement to return a value from it but
arrow functions are more than just
syntactic sugar there are a couple of
other characteristics that you should
know first of all they will always be
expressions and that means you can't
simply declare an arrow function in your
code like this and the other big thing
is that they don't have their own this
object now we're not going to get into
this in this video because there'll be
an entire video dedicated to object
oriented JavaScript that covers this and
much more
but here's a little history that you
should know for right now prior to arrow
functions every new function would have
its own this context that was based on
how that function was called and the
reason this is important is because you
might see older code where you have a
function that defines a variable named
self that is equal to this and the
reason you see code like this is because
JavaScript will close over that variable
and allow you to reference it
consistently and other functions for
example if we define a property on this
function we can now reference it using
the self variable and other functions
but the great thing about arrow
functions is that we no longer need this
ridiculousness we can just use an arrow
function get rid of these self variable
and we're good to go now that's more
information than you need to get started
working with arrow functions but it may
come into play if you use a framework
like view in particular so always make
sure to read the instruction manual that
comes with your framework and from here
on out we'll be mostly using arrow
functions because I think you should
prefer that syntax when possible now
another big thing you'll hear from
thought leaders in the industry is the
value of pure functions but what is it
that makes a function pure well let's
start by looking at an impure function
first we have a global variable then we
define our function and that function
mutates the global variable and also
uses it in its return value what makes
this code difficult to work with is that
its operating on values outside of its
local scope and when you have functions
that depend on and you take little
variables it tends to create a lot of
drama let me just explain to her what's
going on you're gonna have it we're all
clear yeah I just want to talk about
what Garret because this is the most
important thing this conversation wasn't
even how all this guy brought up I was
Manning up there then because Garret
asked me and I left the house there
Steven got back to my one-on-one both
both you told me who could make sure you
don't talk about any of us so a pure
function is one that only depends on its
input parameters and only mutates
variables within its local scope and it
should also not produce any side effects
and the end result is code that will
always produce the same output given
these same inputs code like that tends
to be easier to test and also just
easier to think about in general not to
mention pure functions will help you
compose your applications as a
collection of higher-order functions we
learned in the very first video of this
course that JavaScript supports
first-class functions and that means
that you can pass functions as arguments
to other functions or use functions as
the return value from a function so when
you hear the term higher-order function
or higher-order component and react
we're simply talking about functions
that take other functions as
input arguments or return a new function
when they're called using a function as
an argument is a very common thing to do
in JavaScript especially when you start
working with async code we're not going
to cover async stuff in this video like
promises and callbacks because that
deserves an entire video on its own but
a simple example of a higher-order
function is the set timeout function
that's built into JavaScript it allows
you to execute code after a specific
delay and it achieves this by taking a
function as its first argument and then
the number of seconds that you want to
delay as the second argument we don't
want to immediately execute the function
that we pass to the set timeout instead
we wait for the delay and then the
JavaScript engine will call that
function later hence the name callback
function and you'll see code like this
all over the place in modern JavaScript
another thing we can do with functional
code is replace traditional for loops as
you can see in this example we are
looping over an array and then we're
mutating each item in that array with a
new value but in modern JavaScript we
can achieve the same thing in a single
line with array map which takes a
function with a specific signature as
its argument and it will call this
function for each item in the array so X
represents an individual item in the
array and then the return value from the
function is what we want to transform it
to and this is especially awesome when
combined with arrow functions because
you can achieve a lot with a single line
of code and if you want to reuse this
code you can simply set up a function
expression with a descriptive name and
then pass it as the argument to map now
I should point out that these functional
techniques tend to be less performant
than a regular for loop so I feel
obligated to mention that even though
it's not going to matter in the majority
of use cases now another type of
higher-order function is one that
returns a function now the thing you
should know at this point is that
whenever you define a function you're
also creating a lexical environment and
that sounds like a pretty scary term but
basically anything inside of curly
braces is its own lexical environment
now the inner function has a lexical
environment that contains its own local
variables and also a reference to the
outer environment which includes the
outer function as well as the global
script as well basically what this boils
down to is that the inner function can
remember the local variables in the
outer function but the outer function
can't look inward at the local variables
in the inner function as we can see here
from the undefined error now let's go
ahead and define a function called use
cat that is a closure loosely inspired
by react Oaks the outer function is its
own lexical environment and will define
local variables within it such as a
default name when this function is first
called
then we'll return an array that itself
contains two different functions the
first one just gets the name and
prefixes it with meow well the second
function is a setter that takes a new
name as an argument and then sets it as
the name in the outer function and now
we can use it in a way that resembles
use state from react to X but the most
important takeaway here is that the
inner lexical environment or the inner
functions in the array have access to
the local variables in the outer used
cat function so I highly recommend that
you practice this and get comfortable
with closures because you'll find them
on both interview questions and in the
real world
and speaking of interview questions
another thing you might encounter is
recursion in JavaScript we can create a
recursive function by simply defining a
function and then calling it by name in
the function body when this function
encounters the function call it's simply
going to push another instance of this
function on the call stack and in our
case we have no stopping condition which
means it will do this forever in an
infinite loop until we reach Stack
Overflow
let's go ahead and look at a more
practical example using nodejs that will
traverse the filesystem on this computer
recursive algorithms tend to be very
efficient when traversing tree like data
structures in nodejs we can import file
system which is a module that will allow
us to read files on this local system
and we'll define a function called
traverse that takes a directory path as
its argument from there we'll use node
to ensure that this path is a directory
and then we'll read the contents of that
directory that will give us an array of
subfolders or it will be undefined so by
adding a conditional statement we've
added a stopping condition to this
recursive function because if no
subfolders exists then it will stop
rehearsing or stop looping over that
function call but if we do have
subfolders then we'll go ahead and loop
over them with the for each method and
then we'll call the outer function that
we're defining right now by name and
that's the thing that gives us a
recursive function and lastly we'll
start the whole process by calling
traverse with the current working
directory now at this point we've
covered a bunch of different ways to use
JavaScript functions but the best way to
fully understand these concepts is to
get a lot of practice and that's exactly
what we'll be doing in the upcoming
videos in this series so if this video
helped you please like it
and consider becoming a pro member at
fire ship IO thanks for watching and I
will talk to you soon
[Music]